[Music]
are you seeing right now is the first
trailer of the very first season of game
Eternals as usual go so the footage we
see in trailers we get to see sooner or
later when the show airs however one
particular scene when his trailer was
left behind in the final release the
scene in question is a flashback
depicting the execution of Ed Stark's
father and older brother reckoned the
brain will start by the Mad King Aerys
in the same features trigger being
cooked alive inside his own armor while
his son Brandon had a noose tight around
his neck strangling himself to death
trying to reach a sword that was placed
beyond his grip the execution of these
two men is what set off Robert's
rebellion
it's a ruthless sequence for sure and no
doubt would it be tough to watch but he
hasn't heard on the series today with
Game of Thrones coming to its end it
only makes sense for the scene to
finally air
now some might say that sin the sin did
not hear in the first season there's no
need for a trailer in the final season
as well and I would agree with you if
the scene was not a flashback that can
be cluded in any season whatsoever which
is exactly what his scene is without
being said let's take a deep look into
the unaired scene that will most likely
see in one season is that where it said
it's about Lord Rickard and Brennan
start being put to death on orders of
the Mad King but let's get a bit back
it all started when the heir to the Iron
Throne Prince Rhaegar Targaryen for an
unknown reasons abducted Lyanna Stark
the daughter returned Stark Lord of
Winterfell and warden of the north and
here a vein thorn later in series to
learn that Leanna was not kidnapped by
Rhaegar she loved him and he loved her
but I thought video audience know not
the people of the Seven Kingdoms except
for brain and sin this event was
extremely scandalous as Lina was
betrothed to Lord Rob Rafi and Lord
paramount to the Stormlands and Rhaegar
was already married to princess Elia
Martell of whom he already had two
children after Lina's abduction her Ynez
older brother Brandon was enraged and
rode to King's Landing the man released
of his sister in the death of Rhaegar
heir surest him for treason and called
for his father to come to the capital to
resume the Lord Rickard complied Aerys
now utterly mad arrested him for treason
as well
Lord Rickard demanded a trial by combat
and Eris declared fire the champion of
the House Targaryen the Mad King had
Rickard burned with the Pyromancer
lighting a fire beneath him while the
record was just in his armor as he
burned Brandon was brought into the
throne room a leather cord attached to a
strangulation device was wrapped around
his neck as Brandon was made while his
father dyers told Brandon his father was
a dead man but there was a chance to
save him along cerdos place on the floor
just out of Brandon's reach and the more
he struggled to reach it the more the
court tyrant around his throat Brando
strangle himself trying to save his
who was roasted alive in his own armor
the entire court stood and watched this
atrocity taking place its regime
Lannister and the King's Guard among
them the horrific and unjust way in
which Ricard and Brennan were killed
along with Lina's abduction led to house
Baratheon stark in a reign rebelling
against the Iron Throne
their deaths left Adair to inherit
records responsibilities becoming the
new Lord of Winterfell and warden of the
north
Brandon had been betrothed to Catelyn
Tully an ethnos inherited his brothers
pride Hostel is soon after joined
rebellion after the marriages of net
Kathleen and Jon Arryn to Lysa Tully the
House Lannister joined very late when it
became obvious that the rebels would
when ensured this event is what changed
Westeros and one of the main events that
led to Robert's rebellion which resulted
at an end of the Targaryen dynasty it's
a very important man to set least George
Armour and stated that even though they
are currently working on Game of Thrones
prequels the Robert's rebellion is most
definitely not one of them George
explained that by the time Song of Ice
and Fire and by the time game eternal
show is or will know everything and will
win a 7-point when that occurred during
this time period
he finished by saying it would feel too
much like advice told tale this pretty
much confirms that we'll get a few
flashbacks that will summarize all the
important events that trigger the
Robert's rebellion as well as the events
that happened during the rebellion long
story short will most likely get to
final cities flashback in the final
season a campaign to throw that
arguments became and Mad King killed Ned
Stark's father and brother but it might
not be entirely the mad Kings fault
according to a very popular theory the
reason why hours kept repeating the
phrase burned them all is because brain
travelled back and tried to warn him
about the approaching White Walkers
telling him to burn the army of the Dead
before they become too strong instead
whispers only heightened the meetings
already uncontrollable paranoia leading
him to kill the Starks and start the
cycle of warfare that still continues
investors in season 6 episode 3 brain
realizes the Turks can hear him during
his visions of the past and final season
brain doesn't see a way to defeat night
King so he attends to reason with King
Aerys and tries to warn him of the
approaching army of the Dead whispering
to him to burn them all before it's too
late the King hears those whispers in
his driven mad by it the Mad King burns
brains grandfather live and kills brands
uncle well brain tries to stop him but
all he hears his whispers bran says the
events that occurred just before the
show in motion just as he started events
in the show after walking in on Cersei
and Jaime that theory in which brain
would not change the past
you'd only realize it's him and his
whispers that driven Aerys Targaryen
into the madness and it's him who caused
the deaths of
: grandfather's similar to what happened
with horror in season 6 episode 5 brain
world into a young Willis resulting
brain work into present-day horrors well
Korra and her brains control hell brain
a mirror in there escaped out of the
cave Mira desperate and scared screams
hold the door still in the vision of the
pest of Winterfell brain sees young
fellows collapse after his mind returns
to his body
young horror keeps screaming hold the
door repeatedly until it slurs into
horror basically brains possession of
Ellis in his vision of the past broken
will ease his mind and he hears the
echoes of mere screams which made his
night simple and only capable repeating
a form of less words he heard before his
death horror horror was always horror
for his longest brand-new him brain
maybe the reason that young Willis
became horror but the key point is that
brain did not actually change the past
he said the past on course that would
become the present the existing present
time did not change horror did not
become horror just now he's been that
way all along in this case brain is not
changing the course of history his
playing his part in a predetermined
chain of events everything bran has done
in the past has already been done and we
can already feel effects of all those
actions in the present the question is
what other things has brain affected in
past where the whispers met King heard
that eventually caused him to go mad
were actually brains whispers was it
brand himself who made Mad King mad book
readers as well as show viewers soul I
have heard many tales of the Mad King
inspire and John's grandfather the ruler
of the Seven Kingdoms before Robert
Baratheon is sharp the trump
heiress was known as unstable and
paranoid convinced that those around him
were conspiring
however aires ii was in fact not always
met while somewhat arrogant and
hot-tempered he was also very charming
and vicious in his earlier age and his
reign started he made realm recover from
the events at summer hall and from the
war air soon proclaimed that his goal
was to be called as the great orators
twice
however aires and started hearing voices
that eventually made him mad and
paranoid
we know that Mad King was repeatedly
saying burned them all in the later
stages of his life creepy a howl the
door incident 2.0 could it be that brain
whisper to him send armies beyond the
wall and burned all the army of the Dead
before it's too late or something like
that which hurts then kept saying
repeatedly until it's lured in to burn
them all as I already pointed out the
king was not always mad the Mondays
something happened that got him obsessed
with a particular phrase that caused him
to mentally slip what if it will be
brain will travel back in time to warn
Aerys Targaryen about the night king and
his army oh it realize it's him and his
warning words that actually made errors
made which resulted with the Mad King
burning the Starks it's definitely not
out of the realm of spell it is that the
reason why Eris kept repeating the
phrase burned them all it's because
branch fell back and tried to warn him
of the approaching White Walkers there's
another theory which is actually a
theory of mine according to which we'll
see huge twist regarding of how much
influence Brent can have over the past
given his tendency to ignore the advice
so visor people and his irresponsible
use of his powers there's a good chance
that we could see brain attempting to
change the past let's take a look on a
scene from season 6 episode 3 as Ned
runs into the tower to find Liana Brent
calls out to him Ned stop still around
but it's confused because he cannot find
the source of voice before brain can
discover what's in the tower for him
sell the three-eyed raven brings both of
them out of the past it's very important
to highlight that membrane question
whether or not his father heard him
three-eyed raven did not deny the
possibility of that being true in fact
he seemed to think that it could be the
case but nevertheless he wanted brain to
leave the vision as soon as possible
whereupon he warned bran not to
interfere with the past maybe he knew
that brain had power to make contact
with other people in this vision and did
not want Brian to accidentally change
the course of history if that truly did
hear his future sons whoa is that Brent
could in fact be able to change the past
which would automatically change the
present as well in my opinion bran has
already changed the past by calling out
to his father it may not have been a
significant change but it could still
prove that he is able to do so let me
remind you that brain call out to his
father in episode 3 of season 6
however season 6 finale proved that
brain has actually rewritten the past as
we can see that Ned now always here's
Brandon turns around so there's
certainly the chance that brain can
actually change the past and in some way
communicate with people from different
time periods and if sure this would be a
major game changer guarding the outcome
of the Great War brain will do exactly
what the three-eyed raven warned him not
to he'll interfere with the past and it
will result with the Mad King bring down
the whole Capitol which will explain
these brains vision whether it's of the
past or the future while prophecies in
gaming journals don't literally come
true visions on the other hand do you
know this for a fact as in 6th episode
of the sixth season Brown received
multiple visions of the past and future
events and one of his visions from the
future where he came through in the
season 6 finale rands vision of the
exploding wildfire the remaining two
visions that are yet to be seen are the
shadow of a dragon flying above King's
Landing and one in which brain sees
King's Landing in winter with an empty
throne room that has it through blown
off the question we only to ask is was
this vision of the throne room really a
vision of the future and rather a vision
of the past event as you can see in
those visions the throne room still has
a seven-point in star on the window
above the uncrowned
however ever since starts to destroy the
entire faith militant there is no
seven-point star above the untrim
in case you have not noticed shortly
after the coronation of stress Lane
stirred Great Hall changed significantly
the same point starts in the windows
replaced the Lannister sigil with the
lion facing towards the throne as well
as the seven-point star above the throne
itself being replaced with a sigil of
house lannister showing Circe's new
reign so brains and ends vision of the
throne room was a vision of a future
event the crown would have to change its
ruler and that ruler would have to bring
the same point starts back and place it
on the windows take into account that
knee region or day are influenced by the
faith of the seven possibility of either
of them taking throne and redecorating
the windows while the army of the Dead
is marching South to kill them all seems
very unlikely to say least upon revising
the show multiple times and upon
reconsidering all the hints and facts I
made a theory that brains and Dana's
vision of eternal room is not one of the
visions of the future events but rather
a vision of the past event what I'm
proposing is that red cave will not be
destroyed by anyone in present but
rather by Mad King and brain in the past
if this theory of mine I'm sure even
though most of the current characters
would still be around it would certainly
change the course of history in present
for example brain will still be born to
Ned and Kathleen has met King already
killed Ned's brother they were supposed
to marry Kathleen before he burned down
the Capitol however some of the main
characters like for example Jaime would
be burned alive along with the Mad King
as he was in the red keep as well and
this resulted some main characters that
are dead to be alive in the present one
of those would be Ned Stark
since with Jamie being dead King Joffrey
would not exist in a rewritten history
and that Stark would not be beheaded for
false treason it would explain why brain
sees the destroyed on room with the same
point star being above the UH throne
even though there isn't one ever since
Cersei destroy the King Sparrow and the
faith militant Brandon Dana's version of
what we assume is a vision of future
event would turn out to be one of the
visions of the past events the Syrian
mine is backed up with quite a few clues
to hints which you can check out by
clicking on the link on the top right
corner one of the most important events
that led to the Robert's rebellion
execution of the Starks was said to be
featured in a flashback scene in the
first season the footage of a scene
appeared in a very first trailer of fear
and blood but has not appeared in any
air
episode of the first season or any
season whatsoever or at least not yet
the scene was cut from season one for
time restrictions but since it's already
been filmed and since it's a flashback
will most likely get to see it in the
final season it would provide some key
backstory to the rebellion and you
better look at the Mad King and what
exactly caused him to do what he did and
why was it the Targaryen madness or was
it bran stark George armored settler and
everything about Robert's rebellion what
caused it why how and all the important
stuff that comes with it this scene
would have probably caused the confusion
among the audience way back in the first
season but now that we would actually
know what we were looking at it being an
interesting addition for the final
season I think all of us would like to
see this flashback along with a few
answers that would come with it and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace
[Music]